[Music]
caleb is with us in winston-salem hi
caleb how are you
hey dave i'm good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um so a little over an hour ago i
actually uh drove my 2004
vehicle into a tree um and it's it
it doesn't need to take much damage for
it to be totaled because are you
okay i'm fine yeah i was wearing my seat
belt we're all good um
i'm at home
anyway i got an elp
insurance agent earlier this year
and now i'm just curious but like i call
my dad to
try to figure out where we go from here
and he's just saying let's just
once we get our estimate let's pay for
everything in cash and not involve
insurance
and i'm like
why did i get insurance then
um so i guess i'm just curious like what
would be the benefit of paying for it in
cash and what is
the benefit of like involving insurance
how old are you
i am 29 and i'm just figuring all this
out that's okay i want to make it fun of
you i'm just making sure you weren't
like 18 or something because
um it does affect rates right um car
insurance rates so
um i mean you should have normal car
insurance rates i do not know why you
would not turn in a wreck at 29 years
old
have you had a bunch of other wrecks
have you had some kind of violations or
something or i mean you've got like 73
tickets or
no i have a pretty clean driving record
the only time in my life i didn't turn
one in is i had an ex like uh just an
obnoxious this is 20 years ago an
obnoxious um
uh
my deductible is twenty five hundred
dollars or something like that or two
thousand bucks and the damage to the car
was 500 bucks it was actually cheaper
for me to go pay 500 bucks than it would
be to pay out the deductible does that
make sense good point what's your
deductible
um that is a good question i don't know
um it's
yeah i don't know
so i'd find that out well i mean i did
look up the kelly blue book value and
it's like thirteen hundred dollars in my
vehicle so
okay so if you have a thousand dollar
deductible
then you may be in the category of what
john's talking about and the insurance
company is going to write you a 900
check for your loss of your you know if
you have a thousand dollar deductible
and the car is worth 1300 you're going
to get 300 bucks and your premiums are
going to go up for turning in a wreck
right on the next thing so your dad in
that case would be right
okay yeah you would just say because
you're gonna if you got a thousand
dollar deductible the first thousand of
the 1300 is out of your pocket
right
yeah and so um you're hoping they give
you the full the kbb value of that but
if you have a 250 deductible you turn it
in right
okay because they're gonna give you an
1100 check then right
yeah i guess i have some homework to do
then yeah you call have you called your
agent oh no because your dad said no not
yet yeah
yeah yeah you need to you need to gather
some information and your agents not
um
you know if you if you're working with
an elp to get insurance that means they
shop to several different insurance
companies so they don't work for the
insurance company say they work for you
they're an insurance broker and so they
can give you good advice on this
but if you had if you had a state farm
you called a state farm agent they have
to turn they have to tell state farm
everything so the the good news here is
is the these guys this guy's on your
team
and so
my guess is you've got a 250 or a 500
deductible and my guess is you probably
need to turn this wreck in because you
probably don't have a lot of money to go
by another car with
nope i'm in baby step two i got a
thousand dollars okay
so
yeah so i'm hoping you did not take a
thousand dollar deductible on this car
i don't you shouldn't i wouldn't assume
so yeah you shouldn't have you probably
have a 250 which would be fairly
standard so you're gonna get eleven
twelve hundred bucks out of the
insurance company and you're gonna put a
little bit of your thousand with this
because this is an emergency and you're
going to go buy a 1500 car
okay with some insurance money and some
i think that's what's going to happen
okay and then you're going to have to
stop your baby step 2 and get your
thousand dollar bill back up to a
thousand again
and you know then we're going to go
forward from there the great news is
nobody's hurt yeah i'm glad you're okay
man yes
thank you thank you scares the crap out
have you done it
yes i'm still kind of shaking a little
bit
like adrenaline adrenaline dump yeah
it may take a few hours but yeah
yeah your hands shaking a little just
from the the thing yeah i was i was
going to the farm friday morning i come
around this corner down here dadgum
raptor goes completely sideways it just
spun out i just about whipped it all the
way around yeah and it just gotten it
was been raining and man my heart starts
beating right now just remembering it
yeah it's a it's a anytime you have that
this is this is not fun about to tear up
a good car here yeah i'm sorry man i'm
sorry you've been through that but i i
think you probably have a low deductible
if you had a high deductible i think
your dad would have been right and he
probably carries a high deductible which
is probably he's able to and is a more
expensive car and it more of a situation
like john had well and and also remember
when you know if you get in a single car
accident like this you may have a ticket
and then you have to pay to have the
thing towed so there's going to be some
money coming out of your emergency fund
too so make sure you do it all the right
way yeah get all your info information
right yeah because the car is definitely
totaled yeah
i mean if you bumped it it's 1300 bucks
you totally that's right it didn't take
much